[Music]
dr. Peterson I'm considering going into
the education stream /system do you have
any advice for me not to become a
mouthpiece for indoctrinating young
students well one thing I would
recommend is that you don't write essays
that you don't believe in I think that's
a sin I think it's a sin to use your
words falsely and the reason for that
like there's a good series of social
psychology experiments that show like
imagine that you bring someone into a
lab and you have them write an essay
about or fill out a questionnaire about
their political opinions so you get a
baseline measure of their political
stance and then you ask them to write a
thousand words
maybe they identify as right-wing and
then you get them to write a thousand
word essay on why a particular left-wing
position is true and then you have them
come back in two weeks and you give them
the same political belief questionnaire
they'll tell have shifted quite
radically towards the left and the
reason for that is that people don't
think through their positions in great
detail and so if you get them to think
through a contrary position in great
detail than that starts to become more
convincing and so if you go into a field
like education that's really
pathologically overrun by the postmodern
neo-marxist types you're going to
experience a tremendous amount of
pressure to falsify your words you're
going to be afraid that if you don't do
that you're going to fail and maybe
sometimes you will be punished by a
professor but I would say in most
circumstances I'm still optimistic
enough to believe that if you write a
good essay that isn't ideologically
proper you'll still get a good grade and
I guess I would say if you write a good
essay that's not ideological
proper and you don't get a good grade
that's probably a good time to fight
so because you either fight or
capitulate right that's that's the
that's the hard truth so I'm not saying
it would be easy and I would also say
don't make unnecessary enemies right you
know everything doesn't have to be a
battle but now then you're gonna know
that you know you'll hate writing the
essay because you have to sacrifice your
soul in order to put the words down and
then you you you Dement and warp your
character and you just don't recover
easily from that so I would say don't do
that man that's not good